[Music]
ted cruz everybody going after ted cruz
man i know we spoke about on the patreon
but i've been thinking a lot about this
um
i don't uh i've been yeah okay so here's
the thing i don't blame him for leaving
he left his dog yo that i get that's the
most
that's the most relatable [ __ ] i've ever
seen you were just in aruba recently
right
was your dog with you no okay have any
of y'all taken your dog on vacation
yeah when on vacation did you take your
dog
i have taken my dog on vacation when
when we came to miami before we left
that vacation [ __ ] no no before
we lived here yeah a trip to miami yeah
the dog
taking a trip to san diego brought the
dog aruba it's like international that's
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
this dog is like a rat yeah you could
take you could
i'll be honest with you though the
leaving the dog [ __ ] anytime i can leave
my dog i leave my dog
oh i love my dog but anytime
[Laughter]
anytime i got mark living on the
property i can't wait till he's not
getting feasted on so he can just look
after my [ __ ] dog when i gotta go
places
okay he don't know that hey bob mark can
you look at the dog bro i love it it's
amazing
okay dove can you walk the dog while we
go out to dinner there's a video
dove sent me of you walking your dog in
the rain
it's the funniest [ __ ] video i've
ever seen
i never related to your boy ted cruz
more
you look so you can only see andrew from
the back walking mad
[ __ ] slant-footed out here
i look like larry king yeah
i look like i'm being hoisted to heaven
isn't that what larry king looked like
somebody had him by the suspect he's
like come on larry it's
time yeah you just walking like phil
jackson that video
you have to feel jackson you can't see
his face at all but you can tell he's
never been less happy in his life
my dog jumping around all willy-nilly
because she don't know what rayne is
[ __ ] stupid-ass dog i mean
she don't know she don't [ __ ] up the
furniture like she doesn't understand
things
i'm just looking at this dog like you
know how long is it gonna take to dry
your ass oh yeah
houses dogs that small don't survive
bruh yes they do
those them guys we got them we bred them
[ __ ] for the house
there's like a chart of what okay what
kind of dog is it it's a little
pool are you sure about that yeah look
at the picture his name is snowflake
ironically ain't that some [ __ ]
hilarious ain't that some [ __ ] hilarious
okay looking out the window
hold on back to ted cruz so leaving the
dog 100 get because it's not a vacation
if you have your dog yeah it's almost
not a vacation if you have your kids
i believe that too it's a poodle no
that's a full-grown poodle bro look at
that window look at that
that window that's a little tiny ass dog
that window next to it
nah it's a full-grown poodle bro no full
grunt poodle that's a full ass grown
poodle
ugly ass dog i'm gonna be honest anyway
back to this so ted cruz
leaves the dog right 100 understand
leaving a dog
never but you have that's the thing
you're being
in that house leave it in the house you
want to leave it outside the house akash
you leave it at it it's [ __ ] freezing
outside you're in the middle of a nice
friend where would you leave your house
you've got the whole [ __ ]
house where would you leave the dog not
in my house with friends stop it
at a doggie day shout out to pop culture
why wouldn't you have somebody check on
the house you better have a security
guard or somebody check on the house the
security guard was checking on the house
everybody's going through no [ __ ]
electricity no water like
you gonna task somebody to go in a
know his [ __ ] winter have it freezing
that's why they left
no they left because he didn't want to
deal with all the bitch-ass-ness that
was going on in texas
are you sure yes yes yo y'all are being
fake right now y'all
it was a thousand dollars i told my girl
to her face i go we could buy a brand
new dog
leave it there run about a thousand
dollars a brand new dog
with none of these problems that's why
they started making toys because these
toys lead them toys
and i love my dog you can't buy one of
your dogs you know thousand dollars you
know good and goddamn well you can't i
spent a thousand back home in new york
and then another thousand here and then
i was like if this happens again we
could buy a new one
um so if it's a profit insurance pet
insurance bro
the pedestrian is the only insurance
that's worth it yeah i do have pet
insurance i don't know what the [ __ ]
deal with it is i don't do that kind of
stuff
you had to just get your dog like let
your dog die
so another one yeah no i don't want that
dog to die i don't want the dog to die
that's not it
i just don't want to fill out paperwork
i don't want to do any of that yeah yeah
yeah
so i end up just paying for things i
don't want i don't want to do paperwork
my point is
that's i can't believe you're making the
argument that you should bring your dog
on vacation
you're a liar you went to aruba you
didn't bring your dog on vacation i
didn't leave him at the house
where'd you leave him doggy daycare so
with a bunch of other dogs who could
[ __ ] gnarl on your dog's stupid face
the entire time you have no clue
oh we have clues we get no clothes we
get videos you don't get no videos you
got to look on their instagram story if
you want to see what's happening
different daycare bruh shouts to pups
that play in montclair new jersey there
you go
we're out here okay point is yeah you
left your door we also we get some free
boarding for that you left your dog so
is the issue leaving the dog or is it
leaving it in the house
leaving it at the house stranded now
question no heat
question if you stayed in texas which is
what you wanted them to do
yeah ted cruz hold on where would they
be at the house correct yeah with how
much heat
yeah find a place for them no no no no
no how much heat hey
no no no answer the question don't
wriggle out of it how much heat they
have the heat of love
no no no no no no no no the human body
so the warmth of human bodies
right right so in other words the same
amount of zero heat
no oh my god that's a different we don't
really do am i gonna talk to a woman
i'm not talking about women right now
we're not gonna have a logical [ __ ]
discussion right now
how much heat would be in the house if
they're there with a dog
the same no heat right so you're okay
with the dog
having no heat as long as humans are
there but you're not okay with the dog
having no heat if there are no humans
send the dog and your wife and kids to
[ __ ] cancun and you stay and
handle business
yes well now now now we're getting to
where i want to go now we're close to
where i want to go
okay because i'm arguing with a [ __ ]
female the whole time
i'm asking you a simple [ __ ] question
would you allow
dog to but i can't because of you is the
dog warm
and there's love
says that [ __ ] the dog's gonna be warm
because of love
i know exactly how much a dog weighs
from looking at the [ __ ] picture
of him in the door yeah i know he's a
puddle he's a malty poo i don't know i
think all dogs are big
so it's not a [ __ ] dog if it's not
my point is my point is the point i'm
trying to make is this
you're okay with the dog being cold in
the house already
this is let's just be logical you're
okay with the dog freezing his ass off
as long as human beings are freezing
their ass off with it
you didn't say take the dog and send it
somewhere warm
you said be at home with the dog did you
not sure sure
okay let's go we're getting somewhere
thank you very much so
why don't you do this leave the [ __ ]
dog there
let other human beings take care of the
dog while you go on vacation why can't
you do that
that's better that's my suggestion for
the beginning i said multiple times
have somebody else take care of it with
a friend they proved it they did
the guy kept on checking him if i'mma
leave let me find a friend who got power
here you take the dog we can't i thought
no one has power
some people had power it was that's part
of the problem some people had
some people didn't lose power didn't
lose anything and other people
that's what they think like rich suburbs
in dallas for a fact i got friends that
are like bro i didn't hotel
generators people were there's options
leaving the dog at the house that's
where i'm like bro there's options
if we in the house together i'm not
looking at options we're just trying to
survive
if i'm [ __ ] escaping leave the dog
with somebody
don't just leave the [ __ ] at the
house alone leave that dog in the house
bro
yeah yeah i believe in it yeah i mean it
makes more sense to leave it with
somebody
yeah but i'm so dug in on this argument
that i'm like leaving the [ __ ]
who's the woman now who's the woman now
i'm the woman
now i'm the woman you made me become a
woman by you being so emotional about
this argument that's what i'd be doing
i know i know you're very good at it
yeah yeah
you're very good at feminizing i do that
[ __ ] yo
listen so you want the dog to be taken
care of sure yes
you can't empathize with someone who
just wants to leave their dog and leave
their responsibilities so they can enjoy
cancun
you did it in aruba now you must be able
to but not like that
no no no what did when you decide to put
your dog somewhere else
to go to aruba what were you thinking
what would be best for the dog or what
would be best for you i gotta go i can't
bring this kid
what's the best option to do where i can
take a vacation and he's taken care of
it's a dog it's not a kid and you could
bring her you could bring it you could
not hotel that
allows combinations and this is where
cancun is
it's valid if you're like international
it's just different they're not like you
gotta have like
different [ __ ] you gotta drive a little
harder
you might have to get out a little bit
more we booked a ticket oh it was two
last minute
yeah you were just thinking about you
guys so that's what i can understand why
don't you think about it ahead of time
and think about your dog do you care
about that kid i'm sorry you're a kid
but that's where i can understand your
child with some random people that's
where i can
clear new jersey yeah you know the pup
factory people leave their kids with
they make glue out of your dog bro
people believe they're kids with
babysitters say what people leave their
kids with babies i'm sorry white people
no no no no no no no no why people get
no no no no no let's go back on this
babysitter thing i can't wait
i can't wait no no no no no no no no
babysitting go back to the old podcast
okay
only white people leave their kids with
babies indians we would never leave our
kids we love our kids so much we leave
it with relatives
i can't keep back in indian all the time
i gotta be a little white
i love um
[Applause]